respawn has confirmed the new character
coming to apex legends in season 5
fortunes favor is Lobo and Radha but who
exactly is this talented thief and what
are her abilities well we don't know all
of that yet but between the apex legends
website the new legacy of a thief
trailer and data mined leaks we can make
an educated guess again respawn hasn't
confirmed all of this yet we'll be sure
to let you know throughout the video
when we're talking about fact and when
we're making a conjecture let's start
with what we do know we first meet Lobo
in the season 4 assimilation launch
trailer she's the young girl who's left
orphaned and angry over her father's
dead body in the final shot of the
cinematic Lobos father Marcus and Radha
was a talented con man who unfortunately
crossed the wrong person this put a
massive bounty on his head which
revenant accepted leading to the
murderous mayhem we see in the trailer
the experience breaks Hammond robotics
control over revenant who realizes he's
a three centuries old robotic slave and
not a dashing young man with a talent
for murder and the Bounty Hunter snaps
completing season 4s battle pass unlocks
new loading screens that explain that
revenant then went on a killing spree in
search of the ones responsible for
forcing immortality on him during this
time he left the public eye also during
that time Lobo went into foster care
grew up and became a talented thief in
her own right she even made a friend a
friend who noticed that the higher ups
at Hammond robotics have forced an
immortal murder machine into the apex
games in order to satiate its bloodlust
and stop its one-man rampage against the
company with revenant now the newest
apex legend assumedly Lobo decides her
best course of action for avenging her
parents is to join the apex games
herself and kill him
we now have additional explanations as
to Lobos overall design as well her
distinctive eyeshadow is designed to
mirror the blood she accidentally
smeared across her face following her
parents murders the staff she wields
incorporates her father's last gift to
her and one of her bracelets is the
first thing she successfully stole based
on her calling card which can be
discovered in the train yard vault on
world's edge
she's leaned into the Portuguese
translation of her name and adopted a
wolf-like persona but what about her a
Bailey
well here's where the guesswork comes in
in describing lova respawn rates stylish
sophisticated and resourceful whatever
Lobo wants she takes good luck stopping
her this could imply a more aggressive
play style that has to do with securing
or stealing loot
so maybe Lobo is an offense or support
character let's run with that assumption
when trying to figure out her abilities
respawn seems to just love hinting at
upcoming content by Twitter or
cinematics prior to making an official
announcement for example we saw crypto
surveillance drone and drone EMP in the
forever family trailer we also saw
revenants stalker and deaf totem in the
season 4 launch trailer and silence in a
tweet from the apex legends Twitter
account so let's look at how the
developer has portrayed and teased Lobo
in the legacy of a thief's trailer we
see Lobo utilize a staff to both achieve
greater height while jumping and as a
melee weapon she also utilizes a piece
of tech that allows her to seemingly
teleport and of course as a thief we see
her steal like a lot pretty much
everything that hasn't been nailed down
of those three things only one has been
corroborated somewhere else Lobo has
actually already appeared in game she
can briefly show up on the lobby screen
where she playfully looks at you and
flips her hair and then teleports away
you can also find one of her bracelets
in the same vault where her calling card
is located interacting with it teleports
you to the location depicted on the
lobby screen which according to the
mini-map is on Kings Canyon so at the
very least this teleport technology is
probably one of Lobos abilities it would
also fit if she turns out to be an
offense or support character seeing as
the skill would probably be used
similarly to rates into the void or
pathfinders grapple hook race is an
offense character and Pathfinder used to
be a support character so cool that's
one of three abilities down what are the
others for that we turn to data mined
character files on April 7th apex
legends data miner biased 12 discovered
Lopez character model their leaks were
later corroborated by data miners shrug
tile and eye loot games the latter of
which also believed they have discovered
her abilities before we go too far down
this rabbit hole remember the data mind
files aren't always accurate the context
data mind files that said revenant could
track enemies with poison darts and walk
through walls all of which is a hundred
percent untrue when it comes down to it
Rhys Ward has gone on record saying that
it uses fake files to throw off data
miners
sometimes these files are just old they
detail a character who has since
undergone changes so even though the
character model leaked turned out to be
accurate you should still take lavas
data mind abilities with a grain of salt
according to the files Lobo has four
abilities she can teleport to a
predetermined location know how much of
a certain type of loot is in the
vicinity
Celie through walls and put down a
device that steals all nearby loot if we
had to hazard a guess the teleport to a
predetermined location is Lobos tactical
her passive allows her to know how much
of a piece of loot is nearby and seep
through walls if she or teammate things
for it and finally her ultimate attracts
all loot that's on the ground or in
death boxes to a certain location
allowing her and her teammates to
quickly loot everything from a concealed
position all said and done
she's presumably a support character who
aids her teammates by keeping them
stopped on loot and flanking enemies as
a distraction again these are just best
guesses based on trailers or teasers and
what data mining would suggest the
teleport is the only thing that has
solid evidence of being true though
again it hasn't yet been confirmed but
we'd love to hear from you or do you buy
into our theory or do you think Lobos
abilities are something else entirely
let us know in the comment section below
be sure to stay tuned to games but will
inform you of Lobos abilities when
they're officially announced as well as
everything else coming in season 5
fortunes favor
[Music]
you
[Music]